one of my favorite papers on the
platform is actually a paper
um written by enrico fermi yeah
and the title of the paper is myops i
think it's my observations at trinity
so basically fermi was part of the
manhattan project so
he was in new mexico when um they
exploded the first atomic bomb
and so he was a couple of miles away
from the explosion and he was probably
one of the first
persons to calculate the energy of the
explosion
and so the way he did that was he took a
piece of paper and he tore down a piece
of paper
in little pieces and when the bomb
exploded
the trinity bomb was the name of the
bomb like he waited for the blast to
arrive at
where he was and then he threw those
pieces of paper in the air
and he calculated the energy based on
the displacement
of the paper the pieces of paper and
then he wrote a report which was
classified until like a couple of years
ago
one page report like calculating the
energy of the explosion
uh it's so badass and i i we actually
went there and kind of
unpacked and like yeah i think it just
mentions basically the energy and we
we actually went and one of the
annotations is like explaining how he
did that
um i wonder how accurate he was it was
maybe i think like 20
20 or 25 off uh then there was another
person that actually calculated the
energy based on
uh images after the explosion at the
rate
and the rate that which the the the like
the mushroom
of the explosion expanded and it's more
accurate to calculate the energy based
on that
um and i think it was like 20 20 off but
it's
it's really interesting because you know
fermi was known for all these
being a master at this back of the
envelope calculations always like the
the fermi problems are well known for
for that um
and it's super interesting to see like
that just one page report it was also
actually classified and it's interesting
because a couple months ago
when the beirut explosion happened there
was a video circulating of these
a bride that was doing a photo shoot
when the explosion in beirut happened
and so you can see a video of her with
the wedding dress and then the explosion
happens and the blast arrives at where
she was she was a couple of miles away
from the glass
and you can see like um the displacement
of the dress as well
and i actually looked and that video
went viral on twitter and i actually
looked at that video and based i used
the same
techniques that fermi used to calculate
the energy of the explosion
uh based on the displacement of the
dress and you could actually see where
where she was at the
the distance from the explosion because
there was a store behind her and you
could look the name of the store and
and so i calculated that it was the
distance and then you can
then based on the distance where she was
from the the explosion and
also on the the displacement of the
dress like because you can when the
blast happens like
you can see the dress going back and
then
going back to the original position and
like by just looking at
like how much the the dress moved you
can
estimate the explo the energy of the
explosion i assume you published this
on twitter it was just a twitter thread
uh but it it
actually like a lot of people share that
and it was picked up by a couple of
um news outlets but i i was hoping it
would be like a formal title and it
would be an archive
no no no no maybe you submitted it just
the twitter twitter thread but it was
interesting because it was exactly the
same
method that fermi used
you